bonsoir alexis merci d'être avec nous
vous avez évidemment suivi cette
allocution alors c'est vrai qu'on
s'attendait où on espérait peut-être
soyons fous un calendrier précis mais
enfin il ya beaucoup de confusion et
surtout beaucoup de chamboulement de
dernière minute notamment pour les
vacances de pâques de printemps qui
concernent énormément de français
oui beaucoup de certitudes alors pas pas
vraiment levé puisqu'on attendait qu'on
ne savait pas s'il parlait aujourd'hui
ou sous 15 jours
il y avait beaucoup d'attentes de cette
allocution présidentielle qui finalement
redonne des dates de vacances scolaires
et et va fermer les écoles parce que oui
le virus circule dans les écoles
contrairement à ce qui avait été dit
pendant des mois par jean michel
blanquer et d'autres responsables
irresponsables donc là il est en train
de faire ce qu'il aurait dû faire
peut-être il ya quelques semaines son
pari est perdu c'était ce pari de
start-up heures de la voie étroite pour
ne par confiner nous voilà avec cette
étrange confinement maintenant sur tout
le territoire le couvre-feu à 19 heures
les 10 km etc des règles supplémentaires
l'interdiction de l'alcool dans les rues
également alors je ne sais pas quelle
corrélation sans doute parce que les
gens se retrouvent et puis que le
printemps arrive alors surtout pas
surtout pas de fêtes de liesse de joie
et de gens qui se retrouvent
l'idée c'était évidemment d'éviter ce
confinement là il n'a pas aidé éviter
pas plus que la et éviter les semaines
de couvre feu à 18h les 30000 morts
également qu'ils sont à mettre au crédit
de cette stratégie
foot rare que des manuels m'a conquis
rappelez vous il y a quelques semaines
disait à des jeunes lors d'une sortie
dans le 93 qu'il fallait tenir encore
quatre à six semaines et bien maintenant
il nous dit qu'il faut tenir jusqu'à mi
mai donc clairement cet épidémiologiste
de talent ne sait pas ce qu'il fait même
si son entourage dit qu'il est
extraordinaire et il gère à la petite
semaine
une épidémie qui aujourd'hui le dépasse
il a annoncé encore l'ouverture en
urgence de dix mille lits de plus de
ranimation olivier ferrand avait annoncé
en août 2000 vingt douze mille lits de
réanimation qui pourrait être ouvert
rapidement en cas de crise ça n'a pas
été fait donc on voit bien que rien n'a
été fait on paye toujours les cabinets
de conseil tant que mc kinsey et d'autre
une fortune pour avoir des slides
on a vu ces images powerpoint lors de
l'allocution du président de la
république c'est nouveau avec les
chiffres les courbes pour expliquer que
nous allons repartir pour quelques
semaines de difficultés pour vaincre ce
virus avec évidemment l'idée c'est
d'attendre les doses de vaccin puisque
elles le sont toujours pas là et
l'europe ne produit toujours pas sur son
territoire suffisamment de vaccins pour
tous les pays alors pour autant alexis
pas vraiment de mea culpa il ya eu un
moment donné où on a esquissé voilà une
reconnaissance de quelques petites
erreurs mais vite corrigé en disant oui
mais on devient meilleur après mais dans
l'ensemble pas vraiment de mea culpa on
a bien fait a dit emmanuel macron oui on
a toujours bien fait et on est les
meilleurs il faut surtout pas comparer
avec les autres parce que de toute façon
la france c'est le meilleur pays avec le
meilleur président est la meilleure
stratégie
donc oui ça a été très court ce petit
moment d'émotion où il a dit que oui
peut-être qu'on aurait pu faire les
choses autrement qu'il comprenait
l'énervement la lassitude des français
que cela était tout à fait normal mais
que des erreurs nous avons appris nous
sommes devenus meilleurs je ne vois pas
comment
pour moi cette allocution de mars 2021
nous ramène en mars 2020 on a fait du
surplace pendant un an puisque au lieu
de prévoir au lieu en décembre de mettre
en place déjà des protocoles pour que
les sapeurs pompiers les vétérinaires la
réserve des soignants s'organisent pour
la vaccination plutôt que d'aller
acheter des vaccins un peu partout comme
l'ont fait la grande bretagne et
d'autres pays et macron attendu attendu
attendu en essayant de voir si
éventuellement le variant anglais
éviterait comme le nuage de tchernobyl
les frontières du pays
eh ben il n'en est rien évidemment le
variant angles est partout aujourd'hui
il est beaucoup plus virulent
c'est malheureux et c'est ce qui fait
qu'on doit revoir la stratégie
aujourd'hui alors c'est encore une fois
les plus faibles
les plus pauvres qui vont traquer
puisque ce week-end vous pourrez aller
si vous avez une résidence secondaire et
bien rejoindre cette résidence
secondaire des cours à distance c'est il
l'a rappelé d'ailleurs c'est quelque
chose de difficile pour beaucoup
d'enfants qui n'ont pas accès à du
matériel informatique une connexion
internet
donc tout ça va creuser encore les
inégalités tout ça va encore rendre plus
difficile une sortie de crise et la
repousser de quelques mois même si il a
commencé à donner quelques dates mi-mai
pour la réouverture de certaines
terrasses de certains lieux de culture
donc il ya quand même une lumière au
bout du tunnel mais on ne sait pas la
longueur du tunnel alors la longueur du
tunnel ça viendra avec les vaccins et là
aussi des annonces plutôt ambitieuse
tous les français d'ici la fin de l'été
bon pas de pas de surprise par avant
l'europe va devenir le plus grand
fournisseur de vaccins prochainement on
a hâte
mais là encore quand même beaucoup de
flou beaucoup de flou puisque quand il
parle par exemple des professions qu'il
demande beaucoup d'efforts les soignants
ou bien les enseignants
là il n'y a pas de date ou de stratégie
sur la vaccination de ces métiers qui
sont en première ligne
donc on ne sait pas quelles vont être
les vaccins ni l'organisation de cette
vaccination
rien non plus sur la recherche sur les
traitements puisqu'en parallèle des
vaccins si on parle de taux n'a il
parlait d'une tonne ha et contre le
virus
il n'y a pas que les vaccins il ya aussi
des traitements précoces qui permettent
d'éviter que les formes graves arrive
trop tôt chez certains malades
d'ailleurs les soignants ont changé les
protocoles au moins eux ont appris au
moins eux ont avancé pendant sept années
perdues pour par l'exécutif et puis il y
a bien sûr l'idée de dire on va produire
suffisamment et les adultes
18 ans et plus pourront être tous
vaccinés à partir de la fin de l'été
ceux qui le désirent
avec évidemment l'instauration de ce
fameux passeport vaccinale le pass vert
à part l'union européenne tant vanté par
thierry breton qui lui parlait même
d'une sortie de crise pour le 14 juillet
mais rien n'a été dit par le président
de la république sur le report ou non
des élections régionales par exemple
donc on voit bien que toute cette
gestion est extrêmement sectorielles par
le petit bout de la lunette on ne voit
pas vraiment tout qu'est ce qu'il va se
passer c'est l'urgence qui prime c'est
répondre pour dire que ce président est
courageux qu'il est là pour agir contre
le virus et que son action est efficace
c'est uniquement ce à quoi sert cette
communication présidentielle puisque en
réalité il n'y avait pas de raison de
faire une annonce comme celle ci olivier
ferrand ou jean castex aurait très bien
pu s'en charger tous les deux demain
jeudi soir comme ils ont l'habitude
chaque jeudi après le conseil de défense
d'égrainer les nouvelles mesures
mais là visiblement ému macron s'est dit
que c'était le moment peut-être te poser
un jalon pour revenir dans le jeu et
dire qu'il était un leader essentiel
dans la gestion de crise et en
particulier de ce virus qui a aussi
annoncé que des dispositifs d aide aux
entreprises et aux salariés étaient
maintenus mais une nappe ne s'est pas
vraiment étalé sur cette question
économique qui a déjà coûté plusieurs
dizaines de milliards à la france et on
ne sait toujours pas qui va payer
alors si c'est nous qui allons payer
nous les contribuables tout simplement
parce que cet argent magique n'existe
pas et c'est surtout malheureusement le
de nombreux employés qui vont eux passés
de chômage partiel à chômage réel avec
des plans de licenciements qui vont sans
doute arriver des faillites qui sont
nombreuses des redressements
d'entreprise on parle d'une 15% environ
des entreprises zombies qui sont là mais
qui ne verront pas la fin du tunnel qui
déposeront le bilan à la fin de l'année
ou après tout ça évidemment va coûter
extrêmement cher
l'économie française aussi qui n'aura
peut-être pas le rebond escompté tant
attendu par eric lemaire
bruno le maire pardon qui parlait de 2
6% de croissance pour 2021
reste à voir ce qu'il en sera pour la
croissance française alors tous bien sûr
repose sur la stratégie vaccinale et la
réouverture des commerces mais une fois
encore ça fait plus d'un an que certains
commerces sont totalement fermés des
secteurs entiers qui sont sinistrés
le tourisme on ne sait pas ce qu'il en
sera pour cet été sans doute ce ne sera
pas une saison estivale comme les autres
donc évidemment pour de nombreux
professionnels chefs d'entreprise
l'horizon reste bouché compliqué hélas
le quoi qu'il en coûte aura un prix et
ce sera celui des feuilles celui du
chômage qui va exploser et celui de la
dette bien entendu cette fameuse dette
qu'ovide qui même si l'allemagne a bien
voulu a octroyé quelques budgets
supplémentaires et de la dette
supplémentaire
ça ne durera qu'un temps il faudra
rembourser c'est ce que dit le directeur
de la banque de france et ce que disent
tous les économistes orthodoxes pour
assurer que la france en bourse sera
bien c'est d'être co vide pour la
rembourser il faudra de la croissance
davantage travailler donc j'imagine que
l'avenir sera encore plus d'efforts
après ces efforts de court terme qu'on
nous demande pour lutter contre le virus
il faudra faire un effort collectif sans
doute avec la réforme des retraites la
réforme de l'assurance chômage mais
aussi les 35 heures le temps de travail
et blanc bien autre chose pour relancer
l'économie française voilà ce qui n'est
pas dit que les non dits du discours
présidentiel qui risque d'arriver bien
après il sans doute après 2022
justement les retape merci alexis
poulain d'avoir été avec nous